a Southern Nevada summer camp is in
danger of closing and it really could
use your help eight news now reporter
Mary Jane beliesa shares how their
leadership camp is helping our youth and
they need more kids to join
Ali Beck has spent several months
training to become a youth leader as
part of icann's leadership camp I can or
issues concerning adolescents of
Nevada's Leadership Camp involves teens
ages 11 to 17. it's five days at camp
Lee Canyon you're stressed you get to
start over and meet everybody and be
part of fun activities but also grow and
learn about yourself and others Tiffany
Bond a camp board director first started
going to Camp during her teen years and
is now bonding with her stepdaughter Ali
through Camp too we have campfires we
have a dance we have a no talent talent
show we have all of that stuff we also
have guest speakers in the community
that come up and give our students so
much knowledge and confidence we just
want them to be good humans but now Bond
says Camp might not happen this year
kids you know spread by word of mouth
and they ask their friends and then
their other friends and then it just
kind of builds from there that kind of
core base went away during the pandemic
because so many kids graduated and moved
on president of icann Mary canizarro
says the nonprofit organization is is
looking to fill about 50 to 60 youth
spots you know we're in danger of not
being able to have camp this year and
not for lack of try we've we've been
racking our brains trying to find
different Avenues to to find kids
canizarro says Leadership Camp goes a
long way in teaching kids how to be
confident and to look out for one
another as well as addressing issues on
drugs alcohol mental health and more and
a lot of us started when we were kids so
we know the value in it and we really
want to pass that on to the next
generation and and help raise leaders I
think it's just really important to be a
part of a group that understands you and
you can be who you are